on fera une grosse fête de fin d'année
sachez ah sachez-le on fera une très
grosse fête de fin d'année tiens
d'ailleurs c'est quoi votre souvenir
vous sur cette raison parce que en fait
on a demandé et on vous a demandé de
classer les 13 extraits les plus darka
depuis ses 13 ans celui qui venait à
l'esprit ah vous allez voir le numéro 1
dans un instant
c'est chelou mais c'est mérité quelle
est le moment qui vous a le plus marqué
vous tiens pendant ces 13 ans
Jean-Michel maire moi c'était des
voyages pour Las Vegas
j'aimerais bien qu'on fasse ces voyages
c'est un on va refaire si tu nous donnes
de l'argent
on va en faire t'inquiète pas tu nous
donnes de l'oseille on va refaire mais
non mais j'ai j'ai j'avais plein d'idées
en tête moi je voulais faire Baba à Rome
franchement je vais faire Baba à Rome je
voulais faire non non je voulais vous
faire non franchement le bail que je
voulais faire absolument faire par
équipe faire un rallye ah oui c'est pas
mal ça dans des dunes et tout tu vois
c'est bien ça
me greffer dans un gars
je vais me greffer dans un rallye je
vais construire un rallye
nON NON
MERCI Alibaba et les 40 Ricard
et notamment il y en a un quand il a
fait de la corde à
sauterais beaucoup de gens ça reste un
souvenirs
incroyable et je me rappellerai toujours
cette histoire parce que tu appelles
Jean-Mi et c'est j'avais je me rappelle
parce que je lui ai dit un moment je lui
je lui ai dit un moment je lui ai dit
non parce qu'il sautait comme ça avec
les
sur une chronique de le moine
appelez-vous chez un petit euh souvenir
de TPMP
c'est quand vous avez pété c'est ça quoi
non mais non voilà son plus grand
souvenir c'est quand il a pété donc
voilà un petit peu le comme il est
absent dans les émissions non mais c'est
un truc de fou le gars il est il sait
même pas tellement pas qu'il allait
mission que c'est quand il a pété qu'il
a qui s'est souvenu Delphine et moi
c'était quand il y avait le coach en
communication qui était venu plusieurs
fois j'ai trouvé ça tellement tellement
drôle
mais moi j'ai trouvé ça trop drôle donc
c'est ça qui vous vient l'esprit
ah vous c'est pas là dans leur mariage
ah oui tu es sûr que c'est vraiment un
bon souvenir
tu es toujours pas marié mais c'est le
plus marquant mais c'est normal Béatrice
ouais j'étais là pendant la séquence
avec pernicov sur le chien et
franchement c'est un fou rire
je pleure de rire littéralement
top 13
je crois je crois que vous avez tapé Ju
je crois qu'elle est dans le top 13
Raymond à moi devant ma télé je
regardais c'était où quand t'offre des
maisons aux gens je kiffais sinon j'ai
l'âme l'âme j'ai adoré
et sinon c'est Ahmed Sylla quand il dit
au revoir et vous
battre de Jean-Mi avec Mathieu et vous
êtes au revoir à tout le monde et sur ça
tellement drôle tout le monde se barre
et tout j'ai trouvé tellement drôle ça
c'est drôle oui donc moi c'est les
fausses interdits les fourrés à la fin
de l'émission quand on craque alors que
c'est des sujets hyper sérieux le plus
grand moment c'est avec Francis Lalanne
l'année dernière
et c'est juste parce que en fait il y
avait plein de passage hyper sympa et je
vous dis quand je vois les passages
qu'ils ont sélectionnés il y a que de la
merde
ah mais je voulais dire que c'est vrai
donc